hi
and welcome to our workspot session
entitled low latency cloud pcs the
modern way to work
i'm brad peterson vp of marketing at
workspot and with me is our workspot ceo
amitabh
sinha i'm the top hey brad um hey
everybody
um very nice to have you for this
session all right well you know what
we're going to jump right in we got 25
minutes ahead of us and with that we're
going to share this phenomenal story of
delivering low latency pcs all around
the world
and we're going to combine that with a
couple of really cool demos okay an end
user demo
and then a full functioning admin demo
to show you how this is all done
now let's kick the presentation off by
digging deep into the title
low latency cloud pc so amitabh
what exactly is a cloud pc that's a
great question brad
a cloud pc is very similar to your
physical pc
it runs windows 10 it runs your
applications
the big difference is a cloud pc runs in
the cloud
in the google cloud you get the same
excellent performance as your physical
pc
there are key differences though a cloud
pc you get data center class security
versus a physical pc you're worried
about endpoint security
a cl a physical pc can take four six
four to six weeks to provision a cloud
pc
is available instantly anywhere in the
world
a physical pc has a refresh cycle every
three to four years
a cloud pc is instantly reconfigurable
right you can change the cpu the memory
the storage
anytime you want our customers are using
cloud pcs to
enable work from anywhere they're
enabling secure remote access from any
device
contractors are using it call center
employees
remote software developers and a very
high performance use case is 3d
collaboration so for 3d cad engineers in
architectural engineering and
construction
in manufacturing auto manufacturing
these are
very very special use cases what we had
to do for cloud pcs in order to deliver
this innovation was to start from
scratch and build a cloud native
architecture
which very closely resembles something
that google has called
anthos anthos is a fantastic platform
for you to deploy and manage containers
on-prem in multiple clouds and the edge
and the worksport solution is just like
anthos except for windows 10
cloud pcs well you know amazon that's a
great way to sum that up you know the
difference in how we deliver low latency
cloud pcs essentially is
because we can do it all around the
world and put it in the cloud region
next to the user so it's low latency
it's right next to them
but also there's that fundamental
architecture that's massively different
and i love the fact that
that anthos is so similar to the
workspot architecture in that way
only for us of course it's windows 10
desktops now historically this was not
the case
historically what had happened is like
legacy systems were out there with vdi
virtual desktop infrastructure now with
this it was very different the it
organization had to buy everything up
front and they were responsible for
building it all and making it work and
this was only in one location at a time
and so the problem is the end users were
never really happy with the performance
because you know it's like they were
sharing resources all the time it might
be okay in the morning but not so okay
in the afternoon when everyone came in
and also if they were far away from that
one location in the world they were
getting high latency connections
and that was super slow now the it
organization wasn't happy either with
the notion of this do-it-yourself
project because they had full ownership
of everything and
huge upfront costs capex costs and also
the notion of the complexity and the
responsibility of making it all work
now that's kind of bad news but you know
what the good news is you can forget
everything you know about vdi because
that's not required in this new world of
ours
all right significantly different if you
are an i.t person that has suffered
through this before you know what i'm
talking about
and even if you're an end user and
you've requested a vdi
desktop and it has been painfully slow
and so forth you experience that you
also know what i'm talking about
forget that whole world everything
changes now
and it changes now because the title of
this session you know low latency cloud
pc
low latency because the desktop is in
the cloud
region of the world as close to the user
as possible
and they're getting their own resources
they're not sharing these things they're
for them so it's super fast and
wonderful
and on the i t side it's a cloud pc so
you don't you're not responsible for
taking it buying it building it and then
maintaining it it's a subscription
service you subscribe to 100 desktops or
200 desktops or a thousand desktops in
new york la london or singapore wherever
you want around the world
and even though it's that simple it's
also enterprise class
it's tied into your enterprise and your
ad authentication and your windows 10
images and so on and so on
it's also massively predictable in the
world of cost because it's flat rate
pricing no matter where you need that
desktop anywhere in the world it is the
exact same flat rate price
across the world any location any user
and any use case
so that's the amazing part now what does
it look like well if i'm sitting at my
desk you know maybe at home here
i might have a chromebook or a
smartphone or a tablet
and if i install the workspot client on
there i can connect into my cloud pc in
the cloud
and i will display all that right there
and i'm working away now it feels like
it's working right on the device in
front of me but it's not it's actually
running in the cloud it's displaying
right there
if i have some sort of device in the
middle that connects to external
monitors i can actually even expand that
experience
so that when i run the client on the
device and i connect into workspot in
the cloud
and then i ask google cloud to provision
that cloud pc for me in the location
near me like here i am in the west coast
of the united states
i would launch it in u.s west it would
be so close to me i would launch it and
i would have that whole experience
and that desktop would span across all
three of those monitors a fully
integrated
display now to really understand the
experience here what we want to do is
show you a little video the video
is a recording of a person sitting down
at a really inexpensive device connected
to
a couple of 40-inch monitors and
connecting into their cloud pc
and when you do that you can have all
sorts of productivity apps coming up you
could have
browser-based applications windows based
applications
you could even have gpu accelerated
applications and still get a great
experience in fact
that's one of the hardest workloads and
we're going to show you that
in this video one of the hardest
workloads out there because we can do
them all
around the world from any location so
let's take a look at the video now
do
uh
do
so that's what the experience looks and
feels like you sit down at your own
device
connected to your wonderful monitors and
that whole cloud pc comes right down to
you
and whatever you had been working on
before is still there you reconnect and
you
work continue working on your projects
and so forth and when you're done click
and disconnect
and so it's just unbelievably amazing
now what we're going to do is drill down
into those two words we started off with
the low latency words the cloud pc words
we're going to dive into low latency and
go into more detail
on how that's truly the case so for this
uh amitabh why don't you take this
section
thanks brad low latency is driven by a
controlled data plane separation in the
architecture
and this is the most fundamental thing
that one needs to think about
in the cloud pc world low latency drives
excellent performance for end users
so let's try to explain to you how all
this happens
and we start with understanding first
the problems with vdi
right so if you look at how vdi was
deployed before
this was an era when most customers had
one data center
the largest ones might have two three
data centers but because of the cost
complexity of the solution stack you
deployed vdi in a single data center
right and in that single data center the
control plane
the which used to configure provision
and broker virtual desktops and the data
plane which is the users
desktops themselves were all very
tightly integrated into the same data
center
and so your users could now be 50 100
150 200 250 milliseconds away from that
data center
and the further away they were from the
data center the worse their performance
was
the whole industry spent the last 10
years trying to
optimize and mitigate the problems with
this low latency by
deploying van acceleration technology or
protocol improvements
but fundamentally it's the speed of
light it's a law of physics you can only
do
so much with optimizing the latencies
that are
created by vdi now the world is changing
completely
we're entering an era of low latency
infrastructure
so on the left you started off with
on-prem data centers where the latencies
can be low if you're in the next to the
data centers
but very high if you're far away and
most customers had access to one maybe
two or three regions in the world
today with the public cloud with google
cloud every customer has access to tens
and dozens of regions across the world
and they're now within 15 to 20
milliseconds of a google cloud region
anywhere they are in the world
and that's new that wasn't possible
before and going forward it's going to
get even better from a latency
perspective because
all the public clouds are working with
carriers to deploy
edge and 5g technology so that this high
compute power is going to be available
in
thousands of regions across the world
where the user is going to be within 5
milliseconds latency of any of these
infrastructure pieces
now it's not straightforward to start
with the world on the left and move to
the world on the right with any piece of
software right
and this is not just vdi software when
we build databases back in 2005
built app servers or even sap it was all
built the same way
it was built for a single data center
now some
vendors might choose to make copies of
it across the world
but how many copies are you going to
make for the edge world how many copies
are you going to make in the
public cloud world that's not the right
architecture
and the folks who inspired us were from
software-defined networking
and software-defined network had to
solve this problem before anybody else
and what they implemented was a new
architecture
which is controlled data plane
separation
and we start off with wireless access
points as an example
meraki was one of the early vendors in
the space
and they had this problem in in to be to
be solved because every customer had
multiple buildings and
offices around the world each office
could have multiple floors each floor
could have multiple areas
and you couldn't go around installing
access points and control planes and
data planes all over
the world it just doesn't make any sense
and so they created a control plane that
was separate from the
data plane which is the access points
and you could deploy the data planes
anywhere you want
and the control plane allowed you to
from a single pane of glass to configure
all these data planes
all over the world now we took
inspiration from this
and built a very similar architecture
but instead of access points it's
windows 10 cloud pcs
and they could be distributed anywhere
in the world
so our control plane is very separate
from our data plane
uh from a car control plane any customer
of ours can deploy
windows 10 cloud pc into any google
cloud region
that exists today or will ever exist and
event in the future will also support
all the edge regions
now the separation of data plane and
control plane is
very very important for cloud pcs
for multiple reasons so we separate it
out per customer per region
and this is very important from first a
performance perspective
because now every user is within 50
millisecond latency of a google cloud
region
they're on a local high speed internet
and they get fantastic bandwidth
and so they get excellent performance
it's also better from a scalability
perspective
because we can actually scale each
region independently for each customer
it's better from an availability
perspective if a region goes down
only one customer the customers in that
region and the users in that region are
affected
um and if it's better from a security
perspective because we don't co-mingle
data from multiple customers they have
separate data planes
with google cloud another benefit that
we get is we get the benefits of
all the optimizations that google cloud
has done for
youtube as a workload youtube is a
real-time video workload that billions
of people are watching in the world
every day
and the optimizations that google has
made for that workload applies
very very closely to the workload we are
delivering
and so the separation leads to low
latency which leads to
excellent performance and so if you talk
to our customers the biggest thing
they'll talk about
versus the vdi use case was our
customers and our users
love their worksport cloud pc we have
customers like southland
replacing expensive 10 000 liquid cool
workstations for 3d cad workstations
with worksport cloud workstations we
have meet and hunt
which has been measuring productivity of
their employees from home and from
office
and have measured it and said it's equal
if not slightly better from home
and so our users really love the
performance of the cloud pc and this is
unlike
what i'm sure most of you have heard
from your vdi users where people are
unhappy with the performance of
vdi now let's have brad talk about
how what we have done really makes life
simple for it so
we've made end users happy but we've
also put in a lot of effort to make it
happy
exactly thanks so much you know and with
that we're going to focus on the cloud
pc side over here again
talk about the fact that the new
architecture is this saz
offering a subscription offering where
you just ask for the desktop that you
want in that part of the world
okay and so you know what before we do
that we got to go backward in time a
little bit how did this
used to be before right when you take a
look at this and you look at this vdi
solution stack virtual desktop
infrastructure again
in this world here if you've ever done
this you pick a location in the world
and you purchase
all sorts of software and hardware and a
truck comes and dumps it all in your
driveway
and you pull it all into your data
center and you have to build all this
from scratch you pay for the whole thing
up front it's all your risk right
and think about this you got to build it
out so you got cpu network
memory storage net you know all this
utilization going so the capacity is set
to support a certain number of virtual
desktops and so forth
and then you got to put a brokering
system on that so you can get your users
to come in and connect to the right
space
but then you have all sorts of
integration you have to do into maybe
authentication or back-end systems
and then you gotta various layers of
support you got support layers just to
support the stack you built
and then other support layers to
actually support the end users and so
forth
so you got it right so it's complicated
expensive and you're completely on the
hook and that was just one location in
the world
all right and so how does that contrast
with this new architecture you know from
workspot
the idea now is you don't buy any of
that up front and you don't build any of
that ever and you don't support it
either
when you actually want a desktop that's
configured with a certain number of gpu
memory and storage in a location of the
world you sort of click that push that
button and it is provisioned and that
person can come in in
minutes and consume that and start
working in fact
in the upcoming demo we're going to show
you that we're going to launch
thousands of new desktops in multiple
regions around the world
in this demonstration right here in the
next few minutes and it's only going to
take a few minutes to actually show you
that
and so this is the idea with this new
architecture effectively it's a
subscription service
you will have level one support and
you'll have desktop maintenance because
it's your windows 10 image and you'll
help your users but other than that
underneath that is a service from
workspot
okay so let's drill into that a little
more if you take a look at this slide
here what's going on we got the work
spot cloud on top
and those dotted lines coming down those
are the control signals that amazon was
talking about a minute ago
now underneath that this is the punch
line of everything today it's the end
user on the left and their windows 10
desktop on the right
and you want to make it so that they can
connect into that thing quickly and have
a great experience that's what it's all
about
right well there's three things in
between there we connect into
our workspot client that they run on
their device the end user does right
and when they fire off the client it
makes a connection into the cloud and
connects to the gateway
for encryption and authentication and
various things and then it connects to
our agent that runs on their windows 10
desktop up in the cloud there's those
three things
so our cloud is configuring those with
the dotted lines
and then of course while those things
are running they're reporting back
you know making sure things are humming
along famously right
and so effectively it's that simple it's
simple to operate and deploy and sort of
work with this environment here and we
want to keep it that simple
but realize this that there's more going
on under the hood
right so the it organization is going to
see this happening below
and you can monitor all this as well on
the client side
of course the workspot client is running
on an endpoint of their choice
could be a laptop or a mac or it could
be a smartphone or a tablet right
it's going to have various networks like
wireless networks or
wired networks or cellular it's going to
come into the cloud then and from the
cloud
it's going to pick a region of the world
and of course it's going to have a
particular gateway with a version
and now once it's in there it's actually
going to connect into the workspot agent
that's running on their desktop on their
windows 10 desktop
and there's going to be a specific
configuration of cpu and storage and
memory to allow them to run their
applications
and connect it into a super high speed
network in the cloud so they can connect
into their
their files their backend application
servers to maybe to their corporate uh
data center as well as into the internet
so all of this is happening
the itu organization can monitor all
this activity you see all the dotted
lines
all of that is configuring it and then
reporting back to make certain
everything is humming away famously
and then the solid blue line through the
middle that's the end user
the data path the data path is quickly
to
the desktop and then the desktop paints
back to the user to make sure this is
happening everywhere
now the architecture is obviously set up
to be smooth and simple to operate
at this level with one person but guess
what the architecture is actually built
to support
thousands and thousands and thousands of
users around the world
we actually have the workspot support
organization running their our network
operations center
our knock and our knock monitors all
this activity from all the customers and
all the users wherever they are in the
world
and it does this so it can find patterns
out there patterns so we can be
proactive about making certain
that priority one happens which is that
all those users on the left have a great
experience
and if there's any trend that comes out
of these patterns like an operating
system that's acting up or a
device type or a gateway or a region
one of those things might set off an
alarm and we can take that information
and we can share that with that customer
but other customers that it might affect
also right this is a single pane of
glass
a knock for our support organization to
tell all this information
now we have a live we have a we have
this great demo
that i talked about earlier where it's
going to be launching thousands
of cloud desktops across multiple
regions and you're going to see a
demonstration of the noc
monitoring all this capability also all
right now there's a lot going on here
but again don't worry
it's simple to deploy scale and operate
this is the world typically the it
organization sees they want 10 100 1 000
desktops in a region they click a button
and away they go and you'll see that in
the demo too
now even though it's simple it's still
enterprise class it's totally enterprise
class because it's your windows 10 image
it's your corporate applications an
anti-virus installed in it
you use your ad authentication and
multi-factor authentication
and your group security policies and so
forth drive
control of access and the abilities that
people either have or don't have
and then for image management tools you
can use what you're doing now because
these vms in the cloud
are very similar to standard vms using
your tools to manage them is just like
managing physical pcs
all right so with that what we're going
to do now is we're going to go and see
that demo
okay so what we have for the demo is a
fictitious company called worldco
so this is a global company you know
employees around the world
and they have come to us with the
requirement of being a multi-cloud
and multi-region and even hybrid and so
we've got
windows 10 desktops you know cloud pcs
in different clouds around the world
in different regions and even on-prem
and on edge
okay so it's like everywhere but it's
still all managed from a single pane of
glass
and then the request comes in that
there's a merger and an acquisition
happening and we need to launch
thousands of cloud pcs in multiple
regions
and so you're going to see that now when
that happens we can go in and take a
look at the real time security event
feed right
so imagine worldco's it administrators
launching all this and then looking at
activity of users that are out there but
then we go
behind the scenes we go behind the
scenes where the workspot
customer support organization uses the
network operation
center the knock to monitor all of the
activity like i said before to take a
look at those trends
to share the insight and and the greater
good across
all customers all users wherever they
are in the world all right
so without further ado let's go ahead
and take a look at that demonstration
here we go our fictitious company
worldco
has a multi-cloud setup across gcp and
azure
they also have an edge setup in dallas
across these clouds and edge they have
cloud pc resource pools set up in 10
different regions
around the world we've got three gpu
regions and three desktop regions in
google cloud
three desktop regions in azure and an
edge development
in dallas all of this is already set up
as they're using it today
and as a workspot admin it's easy to
manage this from a single pane of glass
now worldco has just acquired a company
with users on the east and west coast
and it gets a request to add thousands
of new cloud pcs
on each coast i'm going to increase the
total cloud pc's of each of these east
and west resource pools to a thousand
and it's only going to take three to
four minutes to provision all of these
that's crazy
now we'll increase the number of cloud
pcs in the west and as we do
the cpu storage and networking resources
in google cloud east
and west are dynamically assembled to
create the new cloud pcs
and configure them and ready them for
their users in the regions closest to
their location
excellent okay while that's happening
let's look at the events feed
the events feed captures end user
activity in near real time
users connecting from different parts of
the world from different devices
and depending on your requirements we
have even more user activity that can be
captured
and fed into splunk and other sim
monitoring apps
as an admin in the system you can see my
event trail
there are my actions adding thousands of
desktops in two different parts of the
world
now for all of these new cloud pcs i
just got a request to give them the
ability to print locally so let's make a
security change enabling printing for
the whole group
scroll down here find the actual
attribute enable printing
scroll to the bottom and hit save and
then bang that's it
when the users log in next time the new
policy will be pushed
and printing will be enabled for each of
them
now i'll open up my workspot client
running on my local machine
as an admin i've given myself access to
all the gpu accelerated workstations and
desktops in all 10 pools
as soon as i logged in i automatically
received a new security policy and now i
have the printing
enabled on all my desktops let's connect
to my windows 10 desktop in google cloud
us west that's closest to me and i'm
going to show you how fast it is
takes only five to seven seconds to
connect to the desktop
i can move this window around this is my
cloud pc and if i click i go full screen
i can show all of my work so i've got a
browser open here where i'm looking at
workspot.com website
and on another tab i've got workspot's
youtube page full of lots of cool
customer success videos
and a whole lot more also down below
open up a couple of pdf files we've got
southland industries case studies
and viewing an interesting analyst
report i can also manage my files from
here
and share them with others i can open up
office applications like powerpoint and
word and just go ahead and edit away
i can run all sorts of browser-based or
windows 10 based applications that it
might even
be gpu accelerated if i need it okay so
if i shrink this down remind you that
this is my cloud pc
i can go anywhere and disconnect close
the client and it's waiting for me there
when i return
before we check on the progress of the
thousands of desktops we created a few
minutes ago
i'm going to show you the workspot
network operations center
that our support team is using to
monitor in real time
what is going on for all users in the
world as we scroll you'll see the
yellows are warnings greens are good and
reds are problems
we're collecting a few dozen pieces of
information in real time for each user
and for all of our customers everywhere
in the world
we analyze the data across all of our
customers to understand if there are
significant patterns disrupting user
access
could be an office network making access
slow for all users at one customer
or maybe an operating system update
causing problems for all users on a
particular device
or even a region of the cloud being
unavailable to all customers in that
part of the world
now we'll look at a visual
representation by pushing on the map
button
in there i can see all the regions world
co
is deployed all around the world and if
i mouse over those regions
i can see the number of users deployed
there a thousand
five in the west and the east which is a
thousand desktops and five gpu
workstations
now let's go take a look at the users
where are the users visually i can see
where they're located and how many
there are in different locations of the
world we can also
look at alarms for any reason if a user
cannot connect from anywhere
you'll see an alarm is it one user or
more users
we have the visibility across all of our
customers if a region of the cloud goes
down
we can see that across all customers
affected only workspot
has that visibility and it helps isolate
the actual cause of the problem
so there you go creating thousands of
new cloud pcs
in multiple regions for users anywhere
in the world in minutes
as we scroll down through the eastern
region we can see all those new cloud
pcs fully provisioned
fully qualified domain names and ready
to go for each of the users
we can also go into the west and scroll
down and show
all of those additional cloud pcs ready
for the users in the western region
ready for them to log in provision their
desktop and go to work
that's how workspot is simple to deploy
scale
and operate well i'd really like to
thank everyone for joining us today for
the workspot session
low latency cloud pc's the modern way to
work
i hope the presentation and the
demonstrations were very useful for your
teams to figure the best way to bring
cloud pcs into your organizations and
increase productivity
you know if you have any more questions
there's a little information on the
screen for you there go to workspot.com
gcp additional information beyond the
presentation today
and if you want to reach out just reach
out to sales workspot.com and we will
get right back to you
i'm tab any final thoughts thank you
everybody for attending the session
um thank you to google we're working
very collaboratively with multiple
google team of course the
google cloud team google maps team
google chromebook team
um ads i mean that's that's google ads
team
um and thank you to google for inviting
us to present at this session
thank you everybody